vaccination rates increase the need for
rapid at home covet 19 tests are also
ramping up but for many they're pretty
hard to come by many stores are selling
out of them and limiting the amount of
tests a person can purchase madison
kimbrough is live in front of walgreens
tonight a convenience store that
normally sells these tests madison
yeah we checked the walgreens here on
the strip and to our surprise they had
plenty of at-home testing kits but that
is not the case for the majority of
places across the valley
i was looking for a place around town
where i could get a quick test something
that day and it was impossible what
seems like a convenient way to make sure
you and those around you stay safe has
now turned into a scavenger hunt for
most as many stores either don't carry
the at home covet 19 test or have run
out heather benson says she knows she's
not alone as several people have voiced
their frustrations to her all they ever
say is that they're constantly seeking
them have anybody seen one where can
they buy them i mean they're just
impossible to find in las vegas right
now the whole city just seems to be out
of them so what's being done about the
shortage the biden administration
announced it would invest one billion
dollars to expand the supply of at home
covet 19 tests making them more
accessible and affordable to the masses
california native ashley chen says she
was able to get an at-home test when the
demand wasn't so high and she was
pleased with the process i think they're
really great since the test is like you
get the results within two to three
hours and i feel like everyone should
just take it if they need to go
somewhere or if they're not
vaccinated yet retailers such as target
or walmart sell tests for about 15
dollars each that being one of the
lowest prices we've seen
[Music]
and when we reached and checked inside
of walgreens they were selling two
different types of tests for 24 dollars
each limiting that to two per person
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now